[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
welcome welcome
to your mom's house I didn't tell you
yeah
this morning after I bathed in my own
urine for medicinal purposes
I took a neighborhood walk you know and
now our neighbor
um we [ __ ] the bus oh my God what are
you [ __ ] for real right now which
neighbor was it he's an older guy on the
bus you go in the back row the back row
is usually it's a bench so there's a lay
down seat possibility uh-huh that's
where you would bang you [ __ ] finger
French smoke pot do whatever you want
and these are all stories I've never
heard before
welcome to your mom's house this is
where we talk yeah I haven't done
anything this morning or yesterday on
Saturday just hits man city buses make
out your finger in the back row finger
and [ __ ] too you said later later we
fingered and [ __ ] but we start with
frenches sure and you know are you on
your side on your back I know you gotta
go traditional or maybe you should wear
it on the dude's lap what the [ __ ] like
the back row of anything is really where
you want to be the bus though is ready
yeah ready to do the whole thing you're
an animal
who the [ __ ] is like I could do it I
could that's not a biggie I don't feel
like it's a big deal
I don't I don't in my mind that doesn't
feel like a big deal now you know why
does that not feel like a big deal I
don't know I feel like there's enough
public transportation there's other
people riding it yeah reverse cowgirl
everybody knows you're [ __ ] in there
you're like a [ __ ] homeless lady oh
stop I bet people [ __ ] on the bus a lot
I've seen people J their D's on noises a
lot you're right and they all are
mentally ill and homeless yeah any
decent self-respect would be like no not
the bus all right look I can tell you're
easily upset about this topic
I'm not sure why you're so upset
who [ __ ] on the bus I'm so bad at it
that's probably why but no you're not
I feel uh thank you for saying that but
I honestly don't enjoy well the process
of that it's really this is I can't
believe you're like I'm saying in my
mind I'm thinking in relation to other
public scenarios for instance crawling
on the floor of a bus here's one that's
really going to yank your dick are you
ready he [ __ ] you on top of the bus a
little Varsity okay that's crazy [ __ ] it
on public transportation you're calling
this Varsity I'm [ __ ] crazy manic bro
day I barked back at a dog
can I ask you something stupid sure
you'd [ __ ] him on a bus no no nobody
it's a city bus I just feel like a bus
is a cool place you could get away with
stuff on it you could get away with
stuff it's meditative
and now I don't get as keyed up at night
I Remember by the end of the day I was
just a dog I gotta [ __ ] drink
something I wonder how Bert will look at
the end of this month it's sober October
oh my gosh I remember when you came on
your mom's house a long time ago his
body was like you know kind of lean
normal in his like 30s 40s and then as
he got older he just let it go older
yeah
it fell apart he aged horribly I mean
look at this but he had a great run
did he ever
had a great run
God nature is cruel isn't she absolutely
insane to maintain a friendship with
somebody like this is exhausting you
know that is unfathomable yeah I really
can't wrap my head around that I'm gonna
be gay yeah that I remember that picture
I came all over it gosh you just blew up
real big boy gosh well all right there
you go okay too much fluid consumption I
have to pee I'm gonna pee out of my eyes
okay go pee pee out don't don't hold it
go [ __ ] on a bus too
foreign
[Music]